obrigado gente é bom só foi feita a
apresentação é eu vou passar direto na
questão que foi convidado aqui pra
faltar tratar com vocês hoje o maior
desafio hoje vai ser tratado desse
assunto em 18 minutos não estou aqui de
olho na um relógio com a universidade
queremos nossos filhos e eu eu fiz a
apresentação é invertir apresentação
vou começar pelo final já dizendo que a
universidade é essa é acredito que seja
uma universidade participativa
colaborativa coerente integrativa em
rede universidade conectado e viva o
organismo que pulsa e volta no tempo em
pleno devia universidade a arte motivada
por uma gestão com base no afeto e
qualifica as redes sensíveis ao saber
que sua sonolência universidade
transparente sem fronteiras mas ao mesmo
tempo capaz de trazer visibilidade aos
seus movimentos mais delicados aqueles
nas pequenas forças geradora de grandes
transformações
só assim daremos voz ao outro a
possibilidade do diálogo a troca ao
crescimento contudo sem perder o olhar
curioso da criança
bom é essa universidade ela tem um
fundamento e aí acho que a melhor forma
de tratar disso falar um pouco da minha
trajetória
enquanto artista professor da escola de
belas artes
formado em gravura no começo de seus
pais eu sou aquele no qual da minha mãe
tá hoje ali e jeans
na minha adolescência informação a
escola técnica somos na verdade formado
como eletrotécnico meus pais queriam que
eu fosse pra petrobras trabalhar na
plataforma é uma coisa que me agradava
muito mas eu estava meio que inclui nada
nessa direção mas eu estava muito já
gostava de desenhar né e era apaixonado
por eletrônica via fazendo o circuito
eletrônico tentando comunicar com um
amigo através de rádio telecomunicação
na década de 80 por aí mas o destino
levou para a escola de belas artes onde
eu sou pessoa
em 2010 nossa 1995 fez o desenho é bom
já em 2002 após o mestrado eu comecei a
pensar no que fazer um doutorado e pós
doutorado ele tinha duas motivações
primeira experiência de um estranhamento
é uma distância do brasil acho que isso
foi muito importante muito marcante para
mim poder ver um brasil distante né o
meu lugar a uma certa distância eo
aprofundamento nas questões da arte
especial na relação entre trabalho de
arte o artista e observador que eram
questões estavam na minha cabeça eu
tinha uma hipótese pode ser a intuição
de objeto de arte como um catalisador de
energias uma espécie de norma uma rede
relações afetivas
acho que não estaria no objeto em si mas
numa previsível de forças num processo
intrinsecamente emergentes é tive a
oportunidade 2003 conhecer o goiás cut
que ver esse meu orientador não era um
visionário artista influenciado pela
perspectiva se beneficie sexta ele
conseguiu essa idéia de uma arte de
comportamento
a idéia de sair uma saída do objeto da
forma mais tradicional é ficção um
sistema fechado por um sistema aberto
responsivo interativo em diálogo com o
imperador
eu conversei com boy e apresentei as
minhas ideias e ele aceitou assumir o
supervisor e daí eu consegui uma bolsa
em 2005 foi para inglaterra passar
quatro anos com a bolsa da capes fazer o
doutorado no pretérito coliseum junto
com um grupo de doutores e doutorandos
de toda parte do mundo não uma
experiência muito muito bacana bom
estourado na arte como organismo nessa
ideia é um insight
considerando os aspectos relacionais da
arte seus vetores de força afetiva sua
capacidade de se mostrar se transformar
no tempo no seu modo de existência não
poderia tratar o trabalho de arte senão
como organismo vivo na sua
a natureza e ter alguma ideia que eu
tive é bem no início da pesquisa
esse conceito do orgânico mas pra pensar
orgânico é importante que haja é um
modelo orgânico com a idéia de ser
orgânico né
eu fui buscar esse modelo é o modelo que
vem da biologia mais especificamente da
biofísica é um modelo que explicasse o
orgânico buscava uma forma interativa
não reducionista numérica não
mecanicista encontre esse modelo
biofísica especificamente no fenômeno
chamado biofotônica vou explicar
rapidamente abriu fotônica fala que todo
organismo vivo ele emite uma luz fóton
aqui a gente tem uma imagem de um grão
de soja é de um pequeno corte e com uma
câmera é voltada para esse grão de soja
durante uma certa disposição
você consegue ver a seleção fotônico
isso não é aura não tem nada de
esotérico é bastante científico até bem
ortodoxa a pesquisa
aqui tem alguma outros outras imagens
uma descrição os meus foto fotos são
radiações eletromagnéticas provenientes
de organismos vivos nas emissões
fotônica são coerentes extremamente
fracas e ocorre na faixa visível do
espectro ou em outras palavras nos aqui
tem algumas imagens ali é fazendo a
medição de bill foto já de um corpo
inteiro dentro da câmara escura é essa
câmera extremamente sensíveis são
câmeras que são usados em astrofísica a
imagem da nebulosa estão se imagina o
que é sair da nebulosa e apontar o seu
corpo depois de um certo tempo você
começa a capturar esses fótons
de acordo com as pesquisas de nada
profits pop seu grupo é sugerido que viu
fotos exercem funções reguladoras no
sistema orgânico devido à coerência
dessa radiação alto grau de ordem como
intensidade extremamente estável de uma
foto são atendidos como leigas
biológicos e seria responsável por gerar
dentro do organismo à rede de informação
através
o corte de luís fenômeno quântico
radiação eletromagnética
eu estou falando aqui gente mas o
artista eu fui pra lá eu fui fazer 11
sob risco em biofísica é em nós na
alemanha
passei lá um meio estudando injustamente
complicado entender a matemática por
trás disso então tem um pouco de
acreditar no que sente estavam falando
mas o que é bacana emf é o conceito é da
guerra
a idéia de que você tem uma rede interna
de luz no seu corpo interconectado e uma
rede externa que a gente está
construindo a artificialmente
isso me pareceu fascinante então a idéia
de obras de arte como organismos vivos
em rede e ecologia ida entre natureza
seres vivos objetos técnicos um sistema
de telemática complexo
daí vem um conceito d pelo organismo
durante a pesquisa que a idéia de a obra
de arte como inter organismo esse ip é
considerando a a influência do ambiente
telemática e veio assim site de criar
trabalhos de arte que contivessem sua
estrutura elementos orgânicos naturais
vivos bom com isso vem a idéia de
colocar plantas junto com sistemas
artificiais e veio essa idéia então de
começar a conectar robôs e sistemas
orgânicos vivos no caso as plantas
vou trazer aqui um exemplo rápido que um
brilho foi um trabalho que surgiu
durante o doutorado e de efeito ele é um
sistema que trabalha com resposta
galvânica eu faço a leitura da
condutividade elétrica na folha e isso é
enviado esse sinal para um
microcontrolador e controla essas
perninhas que são na verdade um
guarda-chuva ele é bastante precário e
debate bastante criativo no sentido de
construção desse sistema é que ele tem
uma forma bastante complexa mas ele ele
nossa parte da coleta de materiais
aproveitamento de materiais
então ele tem fibra ótica para
distribuir as luzes os leds e 19
pretendem ele veio porque a melhor forma
de interação com esse sistema com essa
criatura através da respiração
as pessoas que estão três pessoas estão
soltando o ar respirado próxima folha e
essa é a melhor maneira de interagir com
um pequeno vídeo para mostrar um pouco
disso
em tempo 1
então aquelas luzes começam a piscar
mais rápido e as perninhas deve se abrem
quando você se aproxima dele e só faltou
a é incrível porque você pode trazer um
metro de distância é biologia a gente já
conversou sobre essa resposta das
plantas ea gente está tentando destruí
chá e aprimorar o sistema
bom como que se converte para a
universidade com a idéia da universidade
é como ela absorve essas idéias em 2010
quando volta eu crio o nano é o núcleo
de arte novos organismos todo o conceito
orgânico todo o conceito de ideologia
ele é a base estrutural do nano é é um
laboratório que existe na escola de
belas artes no 6º andar no prédio da
reitoria e ele é formado por essa equipe
linda e itália que são os estudantes
bolsistas pós graduandos professores
todos que passam por ali usa um
laboratório para fazer coisas colocar a
mão na massa e pensar essas questões
tive a sorte de conhecer essa pessoa
maravilhosa está aqui na platéia que a
malu fragoso que minha colega no ano
assim que eu crio no convite à maluca
participar comigo ela hoje é
coordenadora do ano desde então o
trabalho da aluna dentro dessas questões
da habitação e do telemática que norteia
o laboratório vai começar o trabalho
dela que o chassi atualmente tem dois
projetos que sou eu estou trazendo aqui
o chat que se tem uma pessoa
habitacional para beber sem teto
a idéia da malu foi criar um sistema
onde ela detém três sistemas na verdade
um sistema que fica na fazenda com uma
colméia viva
atuando dentro desse sistema um outro
sistema que fica na cidade que recebe
tematicamente os dados dessas abelhas e
simula no ambiente urbano essa comédia
para que atraia as abelhas que devem
coca cola na cidade
e aí elas são recolhidos entre os
introduzidos na fazenda
é na galeria fica um sistema onde a
gente consegue ver toda essa é a
simulação do do que está acontecendo
aqui foi a apresentação dentro e pelo
orgânicos é uma uma variante desse
projeto chamado nós abelhas onde você
pode entrar na colméia
outro projeto a telebrás fera é um
projeto que surgiu da idéia de criar
dois dons bill telecomunicaçôes onde eu
tenho como elemento interativo um
terrário com plantas
à medida que o interaje o terrário eu
tenho então modificação na imagem e na
sonoridade que é enviada para a 2ª 3ª e
vice versa
a gente procurou estruturas que levassem
a uma forma é a primeira forma foi essa
aqui a gente tem um sistema de projeção
via espelho para criar essa pressão é em
dólar
ali fica o terrário e 11 perguntas que
são os robozinhos que fazem leitura de
umidade a temperatura resposta galvânica
os bracinhos eles pegam na folha e
fazendo em torno da resposta galvânica
no mesmo sentido do bim um sistema de
projeção aqui é a idéia dessa imagem
essa imagem eu queria que fosse uma
imagem abstrata que não fosse exatamente
um skype entre duas esferas mas alguma
coisa que apresentasse uma forma do
corpo mas que ela pudesse abstraída ea
gente trabalhou com sistemas de
partículas e aqui eu tenho um pouquinho
da bárbara
o experimento você vê que deu corpo dela
vai movimentando e animar o esqueleto
funcionando as partículas que as
partículas aumenta diminui de acordo com
a interação com as plantas
atualmente trabalhando nessa forma que é
parametrizada ou seja aquela telegraph
ela evoluiu por esse sistema
ele está trabalhando em apoio do ano na
faculdade de arquitetura da ufrj são
nossos parceiros e ela está criando um
bicho na verdade não só faltam da espero
que daqui a pouco o próximo passo só
seja fazê-la andar pela sala e foi a
última forma tá com o metro e 30 mais ou
menos a gente vai fazer uma tem 2 metro
e 80
você vai entrar nesse nesse espaço e
conviver com as plantas e condomínio 1
aqui o sistema de projeção que aquele
dom anterior virou esse pequeno é essa
pequena estrutura que vai estar ali
dentro da do corpo da telebrás fera tem
uma variante desse trabalho também a
gente tem investido muito na pesquisa
investigou e prendeu air bus a idéia era
porque não alguém que carregasse essa
planta num domingo vestível ou algo de
semelhante
a gente criou essa estrutura onde você
tem a planta a performa respira ali o
próprio o próprio respirar provoca
mudanças na planta mudança no sistema e
que são podem ser transmitido a yamaha
as mudanças são locais elas afetam as
cores do cilad e ela interage com as
pessoas a partir desse sistema
mas ele é que se essa interação seja
enviada à pro domo bom a gente trabalha
metodologicamente com oficinas né eu
gosto muito dessa oficina que a oficina
de criar qualquer damas que são essas
estruturas e ficam suspensas que é um
lugar que a gente coloca a mão na terra
voltar pro chão acho que é muito
importante já que a gente vive numa
momento bastante material de um aspecto
bastante concreto por outro ea terra é
algo que nos conecta de novo com a
realidade eu gosto muito dessa idéia de
colocar a mão na lama e construir
essas formas que vão para os trabalhos
nós temos esses organismos solários é um
em oficina de eletrônica para a criação
desses pequenos bichinhos que ficam num
sol e no jardim eles emitem som e as
crianças adoram elas participam das
oficinas eu acho que o primeiro passo da
produção da eletrônica e dessa
experiência
a imersão e um outro um é um outro
método que a gente utilize utiliza onde
a gente é fica por às vezes uma semana
três dias se retira uma fazenda com o
grupo todo e a gente nós fazemos a os
protótipos dos trabalhos que
desenvolvemos pequenas etapas dos
trabalhos e temos intensas conversas e
enfim um ambiente bastante amigável e
construtivo bastante orgânico em sua
natureza aqui algumas imagens
essa nossa equipe nós publicamos também
né também escrevemos e ano passado a
gente teve a oportunidade de escrever um
número especial em cima do conceito do
goiás que a moça mídia temos um conceito
bastante atual é e pertinente e agente
público publicou hoje john é com a china
como um convidados brasileiros e
estrangeiros
o hiper orgânicos é um evento que
acontece todo ano a gente está na sétima
edição este ano é onde a gente convida
artistas para participarem de um evento
que o laboratório aberto deu temático a
gente tem somente o terrário fica
conectado manda sinais com servidor e
servidor é acessado por artistas aqui no
brasil no local no evento e também fora
do brasil em qualquer parte do mundo
pode acessar um servidor coletar os
dados das plantas nas ladeiras do que
você tiver fazendo em termos de processo
e distribuir esses dados ser convertidos
em música em audiovisual ser enviados de
volta para o evento
e aí toda a mágica acontece
[Música]
algumas imagens e eu feche por aqui é
dizendo que os projetos do nano busca
explorar as possibilidades da rede de
forma lúcida lúdica agressiva reiterando
a ideia de que estamos interconectados
não apenas pelas tecnologias da
informação mas com rage sense de afectos
que nos permitam de forma invisível aos
olhos mas que na arte de maneira
poderosa tem a capacidade de nos fazer
perceber o nano espelha o que imagina
para a nossa universidade é a
universidade que quero para nossos
filhos e creio que ela esteja que ela
sempre será construída agora obrigada